the main theme I think as we're seeing
all on the Battlefront lots of Ukrainian
activity pushing back against Russia
which is a stark contrast for months
we've been reporting about Focus Russian
activity the one thing that Ukraine
desperately needs to avoid is being get
into a war of attrition it's a smaller
force and it's a if it gets involved in
that it will start it'll be a war
they'll be very difficult for them to
win surprise and deception have been the
attributes that they're prevailed if we
look more specifically at the donbass
area
um which is where just point that out
yeah just over to this to this side over
this side of the country
um the priority for the Russians they've
not been very effective there's a large
area here that they haven't yet
controlled haven't yet taken and despite
some continued attacks they're not
making much Headway in fact the
ukrainians are pushing back just as fast
at the moment the referendum that's
being held there
um inevitably it's difficult to
understand and when they don't control
all the region how you can do a
referendum and also loads of the people
have just fled the area so it's it's
going to be a bit of a sham whatever
happens if we now look at has sent down
to the southwest region down there here
very different strategy Ukraine is
tightening the Noose around the soldiers
in her son they're being isolated you've
got Ukrainian attacks if we look on the
western side of the city and also the
danipra river acts as a barricade to the
Eastern side so the Russians are
gradually getting squeezed another area
where they're trying to do a referendum
at the moment but of course the local
population there has been very hostile
to the Russian presence and it's very
difficult to see that you'll get any
form of meaningful results out of there
at all yeah okay so aside from the
referendum which of course is a four-day
voting procedure we'll find out early
next week what's happening there we also
know about this partial mobilization of
what 300 000 Russian men of course
across Russia so what's your take on it
Sean in terms of this mobilization yeah
it's um 3 000 it's bigger than the
standing army of 280 000 that Russia's
would would already had and it's
definitely not going to plan if you look
at there's all sorts of demonstrations
in Russia and allegedly about a thousand
people have been arrested already but
more huge numbers yeah it's a huge
number but also strategically if you
look at the Russian border with Georgia
there's apparently an 18-mile tailback
of cars as fighting age men are trying
to flee likewise in Finland Finland are
trying to control the Exodus of people
out there and also the flights out of
Russia are all absolutely cram full and
flight tickets are going for ridiculous
sums of money uh as well the challenge
of course is that Russia will be able to
generate 300 000 bodies the challenge is
that quantity doesn't mean quality and
those bodies will not be trained they'll
not be experienced and they'll not have
the right morale and the battlefield is
a really dangerous place to be able to
learn your trade interestingly as well
the Russian Logistics General has just
been fired as well and I think that's
just another symptom of a bigger malaise
of corruption within both the Russian
military and the political system but
returning to the point about Putin is
Putin's position under threat I don't
think any International Community
inevitably as concerned about mobilizing
it mobilize is escalating but actually
Putin almost certainly wouldn't have
wanted to mobilize it does create some
really difficult questions for his
domestic audience questions like if this
is a special military operation and if
it's called going on to plan which is
what he's told his domestic audience why
do we need to do the biggest
mobilization we've done since the second
world war likewise if we are liberating
people in Ukraine why are so many dead
bodies coming back why are tens of
thousands of casualties now there's no
suggestion that Putin's position is
untenable but the pressure is ramping up
and history suggests that autocratic
leaders rarely enjoy a long and happy
retirement